[Musique]
que cherchez-vous la madame andrée
geiger j'ai dit si vous rêvez que ça y
est je pense que ça vaut mais j'arrive
pas à le retrouver
j'ai pas vu tellement de tissu je sais
vraiment pas ce que je fais je les
rouges tout objet précieux devant chez
nous je disais tu nous les acculer les
pieds au monde en a besoin mais je suis
super fier c'est votre problème le
rangement et wilkins couvrait jeu où ils
ont un problème parce que
j'aimerais tous retrouvés à chaque fois
que je cherche quelque chose mais
envahissent jeter domine plus c'est elle
qui nous 2004 et dans tous ses dossiers
par exemple alors en fait cette planche
la devait être réservé mon mari qui
avait pas mal de dossiers ranger et puis
mon désordre envahissant la réfugiée
dans la partie étroite de gauche où il a
tout juste la place de m un classeur et
que dit votre mari de tout ça alors
d'être relégué dans un petit point non
là il préfère ne pas voir ça
il va juste chercher je crois qu'il a
renoncé renoncé à accomplir du terrain
je sais pas c'est peut-être une ironie
du sort mais je suis particulièrement
ordonné la jeune était tout nu lorsque
j'étais à l'école navale j'avais eu
droit de la part de l'officier de quart
de ce dimanche à une croix verte en face
de mon nom je pense que c'est la seule
cros averti lui pendant toute l'année de
deux courts et pour 100 élèves et ça
signifie que mon bureau était
particulièrement bien rangée populaire
ça situe mon personnage vous habitez un
pavillon qui est assez confortable
vous avez un sou soeur dans lequel vous
pourriez ranger ce qu'est ce qui vous
encombre oui j'avais remarqué qu'on peut
déplacer effectivement le problème
comment leur place et harmonieusement
jeter ce qu'il faut auquel on peut pas
se résoudre
alors en fait on met à la cave c'est
facile parce que ça ne se voit pas en
quoi depuis le
début de votre mariage ce désordre de
votre épouse vous at il gêné le
spectacle du désordre et me gêner je
n'arrivais pas à m'y habituer aux de
même que quelqu'un qui a un pantalon
trop court ne l'est se sont gênés aux
entournures
est-ce que vous avez essayé de jeter
alors là ça c'est un problème je t il
faut des discernements pour jeter
or il ya des choses les choses que
jamais comment dirais-je les tissus et
le tirage des articles de journaux qui
m'intéresse
j'ai toujours l'impression je vais en
avoir besoin donc je ne peux jamais je
ne peux pas les citer je l'aimais côté
pourront soit me rendre service à un
moment donné soit rendre service à
quelqu'un d'autre
donc je les accumule mais les accumule
mais je les retrouve pas alors ils me
servent arias d'un cercle vicieux quand
on souffre de ce que je souffre on a
horreur du vide et toutes les surfaces
horizontales m'inspire posée on a eu
peur j'ai besoin d'avoir autour de moi
tout quelque chose que j'aime moins
évidemment si quelqu'un arrive pour
déjeuner qu'on veut déjeuner faire la
cuisine c'est rien et ranger la table
avant de ne mettre que couvert saxe le
problème ça c'est une tâche et mes
filles le savent bien
non ce n'est pas vrai je pense oui je
pense que vous souffle au moins 10 et
méfiant s'offre enfin en tout cas moi
pas du tout parce que hormis habitué
j'ai toujours vécu dans cette maison
toujours avec du désordre plus ou moins
est vraiment gens souffrent pas du tout
et vos soeurs elles pensent comme vous
entre autres qui elle alors vraiment
aura de tout ce foutoir plc portent pas
du tout et c'est elle qui en souffrent
dans la wii beaucoup moi pas du tout et
elle ne range pas là non parce qu'elle
estime que s'ils voulaient s'y sont les
tissus de maman c'est un moment dérangé
c'est pas à nous directement c'est assez
difficile d'ailleurs de manger dès la
fin demain parce que est ce que quand on
les range est souvent c'est pas comme il
faut me retrouve plus rien elle arrivait
ainsi repérer déjà que c'est difficile
alors lls aimé ce foutoir pas du tout
c'est une sensation de fatigue
supplémentaire de dépression cible et je
me souviens qu'un certain nombre de fois
en rentrant en trombe bureau des
problèmes de problème le spectacle du
désordre de la maison me déprimait
c'était vraiment un sentiment de
dépression plus ou moins profond selon
de la fatigue originel je m'étais fait
un schéma de la maison jets skis mais
qu'on devait la traiter avec elle
respect et le désordre nous paraissait
une manque de respect pour cet objet
dans lequel nous vivions j'ai essayé de
lui donner des conseils bons bonus et
j'essayais de de la mettre devant
l'exemple que je lui montrais de mon
arbre je suis début montré que c'était
facile
c'était à peu près 20 n'est pas tout à
fait vain je crois que ce serait trop
vache mais à peu près 20 plus tard je
sais vous avez l'impression que vous
avez une maison ranger une maison comme
ici avec des choses un peu partout très
en vue je pense pas que j'aurai une
maison en rangée impeccablement parce
que comme je suis
souvent la flemme de ranger parce que ça
s'est un peu partout et je pense pas que
ma maison sera impeccable ça c'est moi
pas je veux je suis quand même au fil du
temps au fur à mesure que là je venais
que ce geste montrait elle aussi est à
remercier le seigneur d'avoir devenait
un peu ce désordre ma femme parce que
j'y ai vu une forme d'humour si vous
voulez et une forme de démonstration que
l'ordre après tout ça ne méritait pas un
nom mais jusque hull et que ça devait
être remis à sa place
quelle est votre impression quand vous
arrivez chez une amie et que tout est
impeccablement rangé je crois que j'ai
un sentiment d'envy d'admiration et je
me demande où elles peuvent mettre les
choses auxquelles on tient et qui voit
m'envahissent est alors comme je suis un
peu méchante je me dis qu'elle ne
s'intéresse à rien ou alors que peut
être que je trouve que leurs
appartements vont peut-être de vie
[Musique]